[Music]
on this friday night sounding the alarm
about a new kovid 19 variant it has a
very high number of mutations why
scientists warn it could be the worst
strain yet as canada shuts the door on
travelers from southern africa trans
mountain pipeline problems the latest
setback in bc's fight for fuel the
supply chain crisis takes a bite out of
black friday a lot of stuff is out of
stock the warning to procrastinating
holiday shoppers and welcome to canada
captain smiley our thing is awesome a
former canadian military worker's new
mission after escaping afghanistan
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight jeff semple
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin tonight with the new covid19
variant that some scientists are warning
could be the worst yet it's called the
omicron variant first detected in south
africa it has a large number of
mutations twice as many as the dominant
delta strain and the wh has now labeled
it a variant of concern dozens of
countries including canada are imposing
tough new border restrictions to try to
slow the spread
we are banning the entry of foreign
nationals into canada that have traveled
through southern africa in the last 14
days
now the new variant is currently
concentrated in south africa but cases
have been confirmed in several other
countries including botswana hong kong
israel and belgium
we'll have more on what we know about
the omicron in just a moment including
questions about its spread and vaccine
effectiveness but first we begin with
crystal commansing on canada's new
travel restrictions and how the rest of
the world is responding
just as travel was resuming omicron has
arrived the concerning new variant now
prompting new canadian travel
restrictions foreign nationals who have
traveled through seven countries all in
southern africa in the past two weeks
will no longer be allowed to enter the
country we really want to make sure that
we do all we can and need to do to
protect the health and safety of
canadians there are also restrictions
for recent arrivals they must quarantine
immediately for 14 days canadian
citizens and permanent residents can fly
home but must get a cova test in transit
an additional test will be required on
arrival as well as stay in a designated
quarantine hotel while awaiting results
if test results are negative travelers
can leave the hotel but must quarantine
at home for 14 days
for now it is just these seven countries
but we will
constantly re-evaluate and assess fears
of this new strain spreading widely are
leading to travel bans right around the
world the uk the us india and the eu are
all using isolation as a means of
protection it is now important that all
of us in europe act very swiftly
decisively and united
belgium was the first european country
to identify an infection the omicron
variant has also been identified in
botswana israel and hong kong
leading to questions about the
effectiveness of travel bans on africa i
think we have to recognize that most
likely this virus is already in other
places and so if we shut the door now
it's going to be probably too late i was
happy to see my family but i want to get
home to my husband and my kids now
emotions are high with travelers now
concerned they'll be stranded abroad
like we saw at the start of the pandemic
world leaders say the restrictions will
buy time to better understand this new
mutation
it's unclear how long the new travel
restrictions will be in place or if more
countries will be added in the coming
days this sudden uncertainty and so many
changes so quickly a reminder that the
pandemic
is still far from over
crystal gomansing global news
london
canada's public health agency says
canadian labs are screening for omicron
and so far no cases have been detected
eric sorensen has the latest on what
we're learning about the variant and why
scientists are concerned
the new omicron variant spread quickly
in southern africa it may be the most
contagious form of covid so far the
variant of syria's concern which is now
driving
this
spike in numbers it's not known yet if
omicron will be more severe the world
health organization has designated it a
variant of concern which triggers new
surveillance new studies new reporting
from countries around the world this
variant has a large number of mutations
and some of these mutations have some
worrying characteristics the omicron
variant has an estimated 50 mutations
most on spike proteins many more
mutations than the delta variant there's
concern omicron may be more
transmissible a further concern will
vaccines and natural immunity offer as
much protection now due to the potential
for increased transmissibility and the
possibility of increased resistance to
vaccine-induced protection we are
concerned about this new variant and
closely monitoring the evolving
situation some epidemiologists say we
should not overreact in this country
because vaccines will certainly make a
difference we have a wall of immunity
and even if there is a new variant it's
not going to be easy for it to rip
through the area like it did with delta
but worldwide there aren't enough
vaccines globally 7.9 billion shots have
been administered about one dose for
every person on earth but the inequity
is apparent most countries are well
along but africa clearly is not in
canada 78 percent have received at least
one vaccine in all of africa just 10
percent that's where this mutation
occurred
news of omicron sparked a sell-off on
world markets coupled with new
international travel restrictions it's
evidence that a new variant anywhere
affects nations everywhere until there's
a sustainable vaccine strategy for
everyone in this world who
wants a vaccine you know we're going to
be dealing with this problem over and
over and over again infectious disease
experts say it's too early to draw
conclusions about the severity of
omicron but it bears repeating that the
best way to minimize its impact is
widespread vaccinations eric sorensen
global news toronto
overall canada's covid19 situation
remains relatively stable though case
counts are creeping up again ontario
reported 927 new infections today that's
the highest daily count in nearly three
months and quebec reported more than a
thousand new infections for the first
time since may
the pandemic has also seen a spike in
abuse and harassment against health care
workers well now the federal government
is introducing legislation promising to
crack down
every day health care workers are coming
forward and speaking out they are
exhausted they are discouraged and they
are fearful
the justice minister says bill c3 is a
direct response to the harassment
intimidation and even death threats that
frontline workers have faced if passed
it would make it illegal to intimidate a
health care worker or anyone else
seeking health care services those found
guilty could face up to 10 years in
prison
turning now to the situation in
flood-ravaged british columbia prime
minister justin trudeau is in the
province tonight to see firsthand the
damage caused by last week's powerful
storm
this has been the operations center
this is the brains right here
trudeau started his visit in abbotsford
meeting with the city's mayor that
community was hit hard with massive
flooding in the sumas prairie the region
is home to some of the most fertile
farmland in the country the prime
minister will spend the rest of the day
touring areas affected by flooding
before heading to victoria to meet with
the province's premier
that flooding and looming storms appear
to be delaying attempts to restart the
trans mountain pipeline the line moves
oil and gas from the edmonton area into
the lower mainland it's been shut down
for 12 days the longest in the
pipeline's nearly 70 year history the
company says it hopes to restart the
line at reduced capacity next week
heather urix west explains
to see the pictures is to realize how
close the trans mountain pipeline came
to disaster in the coldwater valley near
merit flooding exposed lines of pipe
normally buried underground which then
leaves it vulnerable to you know being
hit by falling rocks or other debris
that might cause either a small leak or
a complete break in the line after the
flooding trans mountain shut down the
pipeline as a precaution no breaks or
spills have been detected so far but
parts of the network accessible in
places only by air have needed extensive
repairs the company says rain and snow
are now making it difficult for this
work to proceed prolonging the
pipeline's longest shutdown in its
nearly 70-year history
while construction on the trans-mountain
pipeline expansion project is continuing
in areas not impacted by flooding here
in abbotsford work has stopped to help
maintain bc's supply of gasoline refined
fuel has now been barged in from the u.s
but without pipeline access alberta
producers are now forced to store and
oversupply it hurts and the more days
it's down the more inventories are going
to back up in the alberta region and
when inventories back up and tanks fill
that leads to wider differentials and
lower prices the trans mountain pipeline
opened in 1953 and experienced leaks and
damage due to landslides within its
first full year of operation between
1961 and 2013 there have been 81 spills
along the lines of various sizes with
one of the largest occurring after a
landslide near merit in 1971
that spill caused the pipeline to shut
down for a week
this time with more rain in the forecast
the pipeline will likely be down for two
weeks or more the only thing i think we
can say for sure is that if this kind of
weather and these kinds of
unstable conditions become more common
then closures of the line are likely to
be more common raising questions around
whether this pipeline can remain viable
if this becomes our new climate reality
heather urex west global news abbotsford
bc
and that region is now bracing for two
more storms on the horizon let's go
straight to global news senior
meteorologist christy gordon so christy
how much more rain is expected this
weekend well jeff this region has seen
an extraordinary amount of rainfall so
far this fall three locations have
already broken rainfall records now
we've had six atmospheric rivers this is
much earlier in the season than
typically
than we would typically see as well
several of them have been incredibly
intense now we've got two more on deck
the next one will move in on saturday
with the heaviest rain expected saturday
night into sunday morning by the time we
reach sunday evening we could see
anywhere from 60 to 90 millimeters of
rain in regions like the fraser valley
which right now are incredibly
vulnerable to any added moisture in
addition the mountains surrounding the
region could see in excess of 100
millimeters of rain and these
atmospheric rivers bring in mild flow so
this causes the freezing levels to soar
we've had fresh snow in the mountains as
of late we are expecting a significant
portion of that snow to melt and to add
to the runoff now beyond this weekend we
have another system on deck that one is
set to push in on tuesday so very little
break in between and by the time we end
ahead towards the end of november we
will likely see a number of other
regions break rainfall records
global news senior meteorologist christy
gordon thanks christy
a warning to procrastinating holiday
shoppers
coming up why some black friday bargain
hunters were left disappointed
welcome back around the world millions
of shoppers went online and into stores
looking for the best black friday deals
with pandemic lockdowns lifted many
consumers were eager to get back to
bargain hunting this year but as
jennifer johnson explains supply chain
issues could interrupt that holiday
shopping spree
lined up and hungry to hunt for deals
black friday shoppers flooded malls
across the u.s and parts of canada we
kind of wanted the experience of going
out just early in the morning just to
get a little feel for it last year on
black friday covet 19 forced bargain
buyers to stay home this year boosted by
vaccines holiday buyers are shopping
early fearing global supply chain issues
will limit what's available the supply
chain is definitely impacting both
online and brick and mortar but the key
is when you can shop in person you can
take it home with you as container ships
sit idle out at sea experts warn
procrastinators not to wait this year a
retail council of canada survey found 36
percent of canadian shoppers are buying
their gifts this month another 30
percent say they started shopping before
november
but the blockbuster deals of years past
may be harder to find they are never
sure what inventory they're going to
have on what day so the idea of them
being able to promote
well in advance particular products like
door crashers is pretty well being
negated this year
popular board games and toys like
lincoln logs and legos will be in
shorter supply because plastic pieces
aren't getting delivered to factories
there are issues too for popular big
ticket items so you may want to consider
going low-tech this holiday it's always
the xboxes the nintendos all of those
electronic items but it's going to be a
little bit harder to get them this year
because the semiconductor ship is in
short supply according to accenture
canadian shoppers are expected to spend
23 more than last year but in the u.s
the national retail federation estimates
spending they only rise about 10
as inflation the highest in 30 years
puts the squeeze on shoppers retailers
are trying to hold down prices we've
gone through these inflation cycles many
times in the past we've been working
with our overseas suppliers to get costs
down shoppers need to be ready for
whatever is not out there so maybe try
sending santa a second or third gift
idea in case the supply chain backlog
hits his workshop too
jennifer johnson global news washington
from kandahar to canada next an afghan
refugee begins a new chapter with new
challenges
tensions between ukraine and russia have
taken a dramatic turn with allegations
of a coming coup
the ukrainian president claims his
officials have uncovered a plot by a
group of russians to overthrow his
government as early as next week he says
ukrainian intelligence obtained audio
recordings that suggest one of ukraine's
wealthiest businessmen is also involved
in recent weeks ukraine and western
allies have raised alarm over russia's
military buildup near its border with
ukraine both the kremlin and the
ukrainian oligarch have denied any
involvement
well for weeks now we have heard
heart-wrenching reports from inside
afghanistan but there are also stories
of hope last month we first introduced
you to muhammad ishmael also known as
captain smiley his family was hiding in
a safe house terrified the taliban would
find them ishmael spent years protecting
canadian soldiers and now those veterans
have returned the favor they helped
ishmael escape kandahar and start a new
life in canada
muhammad ishmael's family just arrived
in toronto enjoying some fresh air and
breathing easier after escaping
afghanistan
for a long time i was afraid the taliban
would come and kill my husband
for six years ishmael provided security
for the canadian military in kandahar
the soldiers nicknamed him captain
smiley why captain smiley captain smiley
like all the thai are smiling but his
was serious work so he was instrumental
in helping to keep everything secure
and safe around the base randy scott
worked alongside ishmael and the two
became close they saved our bacon on
more than one occasion
how are you we took ishmael and his son
for a tour of their new home city i see
city a tall building
before arriving in canada ishmael's
family had never left afghanistan never
seen a skyscraper
a street car or even a squirrel
it's it's good city good place
very clean green
and everything is awesome awesome and
overwhelming
ready
almost everything here is foreign
unfamiliar ishmael can't read english
and his family arrived with little money
yeah he's very different and that's been
hard
wahadat wish knows the feeling at that
time when i arrived there was no one to
help me the former military interpreter
moved to toronto with his family in
2011. for eight years he struggled to
find steady work i went to depression
but a couple of years ago wish got a
full-time job and his situation improved
thanks in part to support from a
familiar friend
how are you my friend
randy scott worked with both men in
kandahar he lives near vancouver and
within days of ishmael arriving in
toronto he connected him with wish who
offered to help i'm very happy captain
ismail is here with us that's me very
good for for me i come in very happy
like what what can i say
and there's services and there's some
funding available and things like that
but it takes
a community to help welcome them
and to help them to become established
and to get back up on their feet as it
were hockey puck
government data shows first generation
refugees typically struggle but their
children are much more likely to thrive
and for that reason ishmael says there's
no looking back
i try my best
how can i
do good thing in this country
and you can watch our full documentary
on captain smiley's fight to escape
afghanistan and start a new life in
canada that's tomorrow night at seven
o'clock on the new reality right here on
global
nova scotia's population calculation
next the small province gets set for a
major milestone
[Music]
nova scotia is on the brink of a
historic milestone it's just a few
hundred people away from marking a
population of one million analysts say
it will help the province market itself
and bolster its economy ross lord
reports on what's driving the population
boom
okay so now with your partner
long before she moved to halifax and
started taking english language lessons
former syrian refugee nora alto wheel
was intimidated by coming to canada five
years later she says her family loves it
here among the benefits free public
school for one of their sons who lives
with autism an option they wouldn't have
in war-torn syria i have all my
human rights here it's not
in canada they look
to you not
where are you from
it's they look you
the human accepting more syrian refugees
per capita than most canadian provinces
has helped nova scotia edge closer to a
coveted milestone a population of one
million nova scotia will join six other
provinces in eclipsing the one million
mark nowhere close to ontario at the
upper end and still some work to do to
reach saskatchewan at the lower side but
well past the territories and the other
three atlantic provinces and a million
sounds good doesn't it this marketing
analyst says it will also make nova
scotia more attractive to people from
other parts of canada who've already
been moving to the province in greater
frequency during the pandemic it's not
all upside it's going to put
absolutely to put some strain on health
care it's going to put some strain on
transportation but still worthwhile if
it makes up for the trend of more nova
scotians passing away than being born
and young people moving away to find
work nova scotia is unfortunately known
as an out
migration province but you know the the
immigration is certainly something that
we absolutely need the changing face of
nova scotia society is reflected in
growing niche sections of grocery stores
and in more citizenship ceremonies nora
herself plans to apply for canadian
citizenship soon after completing this
round of language lessons
ross lord global news halifax
1 million reasons to celebrate and that
is global national for this friday night
i'm jeff semple christmas is still a few
weeks away but that doesn't stop
everyone from decorating early so we
leave you tonight with the vibrant
lights of the bright knights display in
vancouver stanley park the holiday
staple was put on pause last year due to
the pandemic but starting tonight it is
welcoming visitors back and brightening
their day
thank you for watching robin gill will
be back at the anchor desk with you
tomorrow have a great night
[Music]
you